This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. There are some things in life that seem to elude us, no matter how hard we try to hold onto them. Memories can be like that. So can happiness. Contentment often seems tantalizingly close, but recedes as we reach for it. But it's not only a place where you can realize that you're not going to be able to realize that you're not going to realize that you're not going to realize
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。生活中有些事情似乎总是难以捉摸，无论我们多么努力地想要抓住它们。记忆如此，幸福亦然。满足感往往看起来近在咫尺，但当我们伸手去够时，它却又退去了。但这不仅仅是一个让你意识到你无法意识到你无法意识到你无法意识到你无法意识到
that you're not going to realize that you're not going to realize that you're not going to realize that you're not going to realize that you're not going to realize that you're not going to realize that you're not going to realize that you're not going to realize that you're not going to realize I think it's my friend. Cleaning outdoors, slowing down, appreciating the small things. One thing that's brought me happiness is my family.
你无法意识到你无法意识到你无法意识到你无法意识到你无法意识到你无法意识到你无法意识到你无法意识到你无法意识到，我想是我的朋友。户外清洁、放慢节奏、欣赏生活中的小事。有一件事给我带来了幸福，那就是我的家人。
I don't think it's possible to find everlasting happiness, but the thing that has helped me the most is giving up looking for it. This week on Hidden Brain, the psychology of why happiness often slips through our fingers and how to savor and stretch out our joys. We all know what it's like to want something that will make us happy. Maybe it's a dream vacation or getting a great job or meeting a soulmate. But all too often, when we get what we want, reality turns out to be very different than we expected. At the University of California Riverside,
我不认为找到永恒的幸福是可能的，但对我帮助最大的是放弃寻找它。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨为什么幸福往往从我们指缝中溜走的心理学，以及如何品味和延长我们的快乐。我们都知道想要得到让自己快乐的东西是什么感觉。也许是一次梦想的假期，一份很棒的工作，或者遇见灵魂伴侣。但很多时候，当我们得到想要的东西时，现实却与我们预期的截然不同。在加州大学河滨分校，
Psychologist Sonia Lopamirski explores the mismatch between what we expect will make us happy and what actually makes us happy. We began by talking about a moment when she felt this mismatch in her own life. She was in her 30s about to get lasex surgery to improve her eyesight. Up until then I had really poor vision, I was almost blind, I hated my glasses, I hated my contact lenses, and so I have this surgery, it takes like 30 seconds and then you go from, you know, being almost blind to 2020 vision. I mean, it's really miraculous,
心理学家索尼娅·柳博米尔斯基探讨了我们预期的幸福与实际带来的幸福之间的错位。我们从她生活中感受到这种错位的一个时刻谈起。她当时30多岁，正准备做激光手术来改善视力。在那之前，我的视力真的很差，几乎是盲人，我讨厌我的眼镜，讨厌我的隐形眼镜，所以我做了这个手术，只花了30秒，然后你就从，你知道，几乎失明变成了20/20的视力。我的意思是，这真的很神奇，
right? And it was amazing. I could see my toes in the shower when I woke up in the morning, I could see the alarm clock without searching for my glasses. And when I'd walk in the streets, I could read the street signs. That was amazing to me. But it took me about two weeks to get completely used to my new 2020 vision. And then I just started taking it for granted and it became the new normal for me. You know, I've won glasses for many years myself, Sonia. And as you're talking about the wonders of, of, of, Lasik surgery, I, I imagine the moment when I can take off my glasses and be able to see perfectly.
对吧？这太棒了。我早上醒来在淋浴时能看到自己的脚趾，不用找眼镜就能看到闹钟。当我走在街上时，我能读懂路标。这对我来说太神奇了。但我花了大约两周时间才完全适应我新的20/20视力。然后我就开始把它视为理所当然，它成了我的新常态。你知道，我自己也戴了很多年眼镜，索尼娅。当你谈到激光手术的神奇之处时，我想象着我可以摘下眼镜并能完美看清的那一刻。
And of course, that's what I focus on when I think about getting surgery like you did. I'm not thinking of what happens two weeks after that. Exactly. And whenever we think about sort of changes in our lives, positive and negative, we often think about that moment. It's that moment that I called a news. When you learn that, oh, my vision is perfect.
当然，这就是我考虑做像你那样的手术时所关注的重点。我没有考虑那之后两周会发生什么。没错。每当我们思考生活中发生的变化，无论是积极的还是消极的，我们往往只想到那一刻。就是那一刻，我称之为“新闻”。当你得知，哦，我的视力完美了。
Or you get that new job where you win the lottery. But we don't sort of think about what happens, as you say, in the two weeks, two months, two years after that. I'm wondering if the problem is especially acute when it comes to questions involving pain or disability. So for example, in your case, you spent many years not being able to see clearly, you had the sudden moment of transformation, and two weeks later, you got used to it. Is part of the reason this happens, do you think, that we actually have a relatively poor memory for pain or disabilities or shortcomings, once they're in the rearview mirror,
或者你得到了那份新工作，或者中了彩票。但我们并没有去思考，正如你所说，在那之后的两周、两个月、两年里会发生什么。我想知道，当涉及到有关疼痛或残疾的问题时，这个问题是否特别严重？例如，在你的案例中，你多年来无法看清东西，你经历了突然的转变时刻，两周后，你就习惯了。你认为这发生的部分原因是我们一旦将疼痛、残疾或缺陷抛在脑后，我们对它们的记忆实际上相对较差吗？
they really vanish from our attention. Yes, a really great point. I had really thought of it that way. You can argue that this evolutionarily adaptive, right, for us to sort of forget the pain or the misery that we experienced before and we move on. Another example I like to use is I have pretty bad allergies and you know that feeling you have, you know, the running nose in your eyes are itchy and your throat is itchy, but then sometimes they just disappear and then I feel great or I feel neutral and I completely forget what it's like to have that allergy feeling again until it comes back. Sonia has noticed the fleeting nature of joy in her professional life as well.
它们真的从我们的注意力中消失了。是的，这是一个非常好的观点。我确实是那样想的。你可以说这在进化上是适应性的，对吧，让我们忘记之前经历的痛苦或苦难，然后继续前进。我喜欢用的另一个例子是，我有很严重的过敏，你知道那种感觉，流鼻涕、眼睛发痒、喉咙发痒，但有时它们就消失了，然后我感觉很好，或者感觉很正常，我完全忘记了那种过敏的感觉是什么样的，直到它再次出现。索尼娅在她的职业生涯中也注意到了快乐的短暂性。
Starting in college, I had this dream about becoming a professor. I remember taking it to the Shakespeare class and watching the professor and I wanted to be her. I wanted to stand at the stage. That was like freshman year, I think. But it was really, really hard, especially grad school, lots of ups and downs. And you know, and I finally got my dream job. Again, you get the news, oh, I have this job where I have my PhD.
从大学开始，我就有一个成为教授的梦想。我记得上莎士比亚课时看着那位教授，我想成为她。我想站在讲台上。我想那是大一的时候。但这真的非常非常难，尤其是研究生院，有很多起起落落。你知道，我终于得到了我梦想的工作。同样，你得到了“新闻”，哦，我有这份工作了，我有博士学位了。
Now people can call me doctor, you know, that was very exciting for a couple of days. But it's a little anticlimactic. And I still remember the day I got tenure, my husband came home from work. And I was sitting on you know, on my bed where I work in front of my laptop and he's like, what are you doing? And I'm like, well, I'm working, you know, and he's like, why are you working? You got tenure today. Like,
现在人们可以叫我博士了，你知道，那几天非常令人兴奋。但这有点虎头蛇尾。我还记得我获得终身教职的那天，我丈夫下班回家。我正坐在床上，在笔记本电脑前工作，他问：“你在做什么？”我说：“我在工作。”他说：“你为什么要工作？你今天获得终身教职了。”我说，
well, because, yeah, I know that's what I'm doing. But it's funny, my PhD advisor, Lee Ross, who, you know, he's a giant figure in my field of psychology, but in my life and career as well, of course. But he had the saying, he used to say it all the time, he said, there are only two things in life that they're all that they're cracked up to be, and that sex and tenure. And he was wrong. I mean, at least about tenure. And, and you know, the research shows that people get used to tenure. I actually added a third item to the list, which is Paris, you know, you think it's going to be great and you go and it's really just as great as you think it is. But anyway, it's another example that it's one of those domains where you think it's going to be great and it is great. But then you start
“嗯，因为，我知道，这就是我在做的事。”但很有趣，我的博士导师李·罗斯，你知道，他是心理学领域的一位巨人，当然也是我生活和职业生涯中的巨人。但他有一句口头禅，他总是说，他说，生活中只有两件事是名副其实的，那就是性和终身教职。但他错了。我是说，至少关于终身教职是这样。而且，你知道，研究表明人们会习惯终身教职。我实际上在名单上加了第三项，那就是巴黎，你知道，你以为它会很棒，当你去了之后，它确实和你想象的一样棒。但无论如何，这是另一个例子，在某些领域你认为它会很棒，它确实很棒。但随后你开始
focusing on the next thing. You start focusing on the stress or now I have to teach and I have to apply for grants and do the thing that having the job requires. You see the same thing, of course, on different scales and different people's lives. Megan Markle experienced some of this when she joined the British Royal family, as almost everyone knows, of course, she's an American actor who married Prince Harry, one of the heirs to the British throne. Now, that sounds like it's right out of a fairy tale, but here's how she described what life was actually like as a princess. In this clip, Sonja, she uses the inside a term for the royal family. She calls it the firm.
关注下一件事。你开始关注压力，或者现在我必须教书，我必须申请拨款，做这份工作所要求的事情。当然，你在不同规模和不同人的生活中看到了同样的事情。梅根·马克尔在加入英国王室时也经历了一些这样的事情，正如几乎每个人都知道的那样，她是一位嫁给哈里王子的美国演员，哈里王子是英国王位继承人之一。现在，这听起来像是童话故事里的情节，但以下是她描述作为王妃的真实生活。在这个片段中，索尼娅，她使用了王室内部的一个术语。她称之为“公司”。
I remember so often people within the firm would say, well, you can't do this because it'll look like that. You can't, so even can I go and have lunch with my friends? No, no, no, you're oversaturated, you're everywhere. And I said, I've left the house twice in four months. I'm everywhere, but I am nowhere. And from that standpoint, I continue to say to people, I know there's an obsession with how things look, but as anyone talked about how it feels? Because right now I could not feel lonely.
我记得公司里的人经常说，嗯，你不能这样做，因为那样看起来不好。你不能，甚至我能和朋友吃午饭吗？不，不，不，你过度曝光了，你无处不在。我说，我四个月内只出过两次门。我无处不在，但我又无处可去。从这个角度来看，我继续对人们说，我知道大家对事情看起来怎么样很着迷，但有人谈论过感觉怎么样吗？因为现在我无法感到孤独。
Can you talk a moment so near about the mismatch she is describing how something looks, especially from the outside and how it feels on the inside? Yeah, it's a beautiful quote, you know, because again, when we think about like, what would be like to be a princess, you know, or whatever this we want to be, we kind of focused on like the most salient change between, you know, my life today and, you know, the life of the princess. But we don't really think about like what daily life,
索尼娅，你能谈谈她所描述的这种错位吗？事情看起来怎么样，尤其是从外部看，以及内部感觉怎么样？是的，这是一句很棒的话，你知道，因为同样地，当我们思考成为一名王妃会是什么样子，或者任何我们想要成为的样子时，我们有点专注于我今天的生活和王妃的生活之间最显著的变化。但我们并没有真正思考日常生活，
you know, as Megan Markle said, what daily life would actually feel like, you know, in some of the hassles, some of the monotony, some of the loneliness, we just sort of think like, again, about the news. It's similar to sort of having money or not. Like, you know, if someone said to me, oh, you're gonna get a million dollars, you know,
正如梅根·马克尔所说，日常生活实际上会是什么感觉，你知道，一些麻烦，一些单调，一些孤独，我们只是有点像，再次想到“新闻”。这类似于有钱或没钱。就像，如果有人对我说，哦，你会得到一百万美元，你知道，
but what does it mean once you have it, you know, what is your life gonna be? But then after I get that million dollars or after I learn I'm a princess, then I have to go to the dentist, you know, or then I have to, you know, deal with my kids tantrum, right? So daily life and Dan Gilbert is, you know, talks about this beautifully in a sort of daily life is mostly about all these sort of mundane things, not about that kind of life change that you think is going to, you know, make you forever happy or forever unhappy for that matter.
但一旦你拥有了它，这意味着什么，你知道，你的生活会是什么样？但在我得到那一百万美元或者得知我成为王妃之后，我还是得去看牙医，你知道，或者我还是得处理我孩子发脾气的问题，对吧？所以日常生活，丹·吉尔伯特谈论得非常精彩，日常生活大多是关于所有这些平凡的事情，而不是那种你认为会让你永远快乐或永远不快乐的生活改变。
that you're making forever happy or forever unhappy for that matter. I want to look at one of the domain where our expectations are often confounded by reality. And you talk about this in your book, The Myths of Happiness. And this has to do with love and personal relationships. Now, these mismatches are a staple of many television shows and movies. In the comedy This Is 40, a long time married couple find themselves bickering all the time. We're like business associates. We're like brother and sister. There's no passion there. We're not like brother and sister. You know we're like Simon and Garfunkel. And somehow you turn me into Garfunkel. I don't
让你永远快乐或永远不快乐。我想看看另一个我们的期望经常被现实所困扰的领域。你在你的书《幸福的神话》中谈到了这一点。这与爱情和人际关系有关。现在，这些错位是许多电视节目和电影的主题。在喜剧《40岁》中，一对结婚已久的夫妇发现他们一直在争吵。“我们就像商业伙伴。我们就像兄弟姐妹。没有激情。我们不像兄弟姐妹。你知道我们就像西蒙和加芬克尔。不知何故你把我变成了加芬克尔。”我甚至
even know what that means. Art Garfunkel. What's like Simon and Garfunkel. And somehow you turn me into Garfunkel. I don't even know what that means. Art Garfunkel. What's wrong with Art Garfunkel? He has a beautiful voice. He's got an amazing voice. He could put a harmony to anything. But what I'm saying is that you turned me into him. What the hell are you talking about?
不知道那是什么意思。阿特·加芬克尔。就像西蒙和加芬克尔。不知何故你把我变成了加芬克尔。我甚至不知道那是什么意思。阿特·加芬克尔。阿特·加芬克尔有什么问题？他有一副美丽的嗓音。他有一副惊人的嗓音。他能为任何东西配上和声。但我说的是你把我变成了他。你在胡说什么？
What? Simon controls him. That's because Simon writes the f***ing songs. He's the better one. Of course, this sounds much less funny when it happens to you. Sonya and your book you talk about this mismatch between our expectations and reality
什么？西蒙控制他。那是因为西蒙写了那些该死的歌。他是更好的那个。当然，当这种事发生在你身上时，听起来就没那么好笑了。索尼娅，在你的书中，你谈到了我们的期望与现实之间的这种错位
when it comes to love and marriage. Could I ask you what your own experience has been in love and marriage and whether you've seen first hand what your research has shown? I'll tell you, but I hope that my husband is not listening to this episode. So, by the way, I love that movie. So, yeah, what happens is, you know, passionate love
当涉及到爱情和婚姻时。我可以问问你自己在爱情和婚姻中的经历吗？你是否亲眼见证了你的研究结果？我会告诉你，但我希望我丈夫没有在听这一集。顺便说一句，我喜欢那部电影。所以，是的，发生的事情是，你知道，激情之爱
tends to turn to companion love. And companion love is beautiful. You know, you really love and trust your partner. They're your best friend, but passion fades in almost all good relationships. It only doesn't fade in bad relationships, abusive ones. And so, and yeah, that happened to me, I think to a great extent,
往往会变成伴侣之爱。伴侣之爱是美丽的。你知道，你真的爱并信任你的伴侣。他们是你最好的朋友，但激情在几乎所有好的关系中都会消退。它只在糟糕的关系中，即虐待关系中不会消退。所以，是的，那发生在我身上，我认为在很大程度上，
it happens to like almost every couple where the first weeks, months are just incredible, right, that honeymoon period, but then you transition to sort of a more kind of best friend period. But when we think about getting married, when we think about love and romance, so many people focus on the wedding.
它发生在几乎每一对夫妇身上，最初的几周、几个月真是不可思议，对吧，那是蜜月期，但随后你过渡到一种更像是最好的朋友的时期。但当我们考虑结婚时，当我们考虑爱情和浪漫时，很多人关注的是婚礼。
But really, it's just one day, you know, really, it's really the marriage you should focus on. And so, anyway, so passion, I hate to tell this to your listeners, but, you know, passion doesn't tend to last. This is why many movies and TV shows about love end with couples overcoming hurdles to get together. The story ends with the wedding, because what comes afterwards
但实际上，那只是一天，你知道，真的，你应该关注的是婚姻。所以，无论如何，所以激情，我不想告诉你的听众，但是，你知道，激情往往不会持久。这就是为什么许多关于爱情的电影和电视节目都以情侣克服障碍走到一起而结束。故事在婚礼时结束，因为接下来发生的事情
is often narratively unsatisfying. I like to go back to sort of evolutionary explanations for things. You know, you could imagine that like if passionate love did not fade, then life would be difficult. There's a line in the movie, I think, as before sunset. Something like if passionate love didn't fade, then we'd never get anything done. Oh, I know.
在叙事上往往是不令人满意的。我喜欢回到对事物的进化解释。你知道，你可以想象，如果激情之爱没有消退，那么生活将会很困难。电影《爱在日落黄昏时》里有一句台词，我想是这样的。大概是如果激情之爱没有消退，那么我们就永远无法完成任何事情。哦，我知道。
And God, otherwise we would end up with aneurysm. If we weren't in that form to study of excitement, right? We would end up doing nothing at all with our lives. Do you think you would? You know, we would be, right? You know, remember what it's like when you're first in love and that's all you can think of, right? You can't even really like focus on friendship.
天哪，否则我们最终会得动脉瘤。如果我们不处于那种兴奋的状态，对吧？我们最终将一事无成。你认为你会吗？你知道，我们会，对吧？你知道，记住当你第一次坠入爱河时是什么感觉，那是你唯一能想到的，对吧？你甚至无法真正专注于友谊。
You all always think about it as that new love of yours, right? So maybe it's a good thing that it fades a little bit. [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a new love of yours, right? [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a new love of yours, right? [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a new love of yours, right? [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a new love of yours, right? [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a new love of yours, right? [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a new love of yours, right? [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a new love of yours, right? [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a new love of yours, right? [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a new love of yours, right? [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a new love of yours, right? [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a new love of yours, right? [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a new love of yours, right? [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a new love of yours, right? [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a new love of yours, right? [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a new love of yours, right? [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a new love of yours, right? [♪ Music playing in background, and then the next one is a good night of sleep? You know people don't think about how much sleep contributes to your happiness. And unless you last night I did not have a good night of sleep. We have a heat wave here in where I live in Santa Monica and so it was all too hot for me but but sleep really does contribute to happiness. But in a way that's kind of invisible, you just sort of feel good. And you don't realize it's because you had good sleep. Isn't it interesting, Sonya, that we're often very aware when we don't have a good night of sleep
你总是把它想成你的那份新爱，对吧？所以也许它消退一点是一件好事。[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是你的那份新爱，对吧？[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是你的那份新爱，对吧？[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是你的那份新爱，对吧？[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是你的那份新爱，对吧？[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是你的那份新爱，对吧？[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是你的那份新爱，对吧？[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是你的那份新爱，对吧？[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是你的那份新爱，对吧？[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是你的那份新爱，对吧？[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是你的那份新爱，对吧？[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是你的那份新爱，对吧？[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是你的那份新爱，对吧？[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是你的那份新爱，对吧？[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是你的那份新爱，对吧？[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是你的那份新爱，对吧？[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是你的那份新爱，对吧？[♪ 背景音乐播放，下一段是睡个好觉？你知道人们没有考虑到睡眠对你的幸福有多大贡献。除非你昨晚我没有睡个好觉。我住的圣莫尼卡这里有热浪，所以对我来说太热了，但是睡眠确实有助于幸福。但以一种隐形的方式，你只是感觉很好。而你没有意识到这是因为你睡了个好觉。索尼娅，这不是很奇怪吗，我们经常很清楚什么时候没睡好，
because we can see the effect that it has in our mood and how things go and how we react to the world. But when we have a good night of sleep, we don't spend a moment to say, I should be grateful for having this good night of sleep because in fact, I feel very, very different. So we notice things when they don't go our way and we ignore things when they do.
因为我们可以看到它对我们的情绪、事情的进展以及我们对世界的反应所产生的影响。但当我们睡个好觉时，我们却不会花一点时间说，我应该为睡了个好觉而感恩，因为事实上，我感觉非常非常不同。所以我们注意到事情不顺心的时候，而忽略了事情顺心的时候。
Exactly, and this is part of the bad is stronger than good phenomena. We notice bad, again, it's adaptive, it's functional for us to kind of pay attention to bad things, to threats in our environment and, you know, adversities. We tend to take the good for granted. When we come back, the intricate brain psychology that produces these mismatches and how we can trick the machinery in our minds into making ourselves a little happier. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan.
没错，这是“坏比好更强烈”现象的一部分。我们注意到坏事，同样，这是适应性的，我们关注坏事、环境中的威胁和逆境对我们来说是有功能的。我们倾向于把好事视为理所当然。回来后，我们将探讨产生这些错位的复杂大脑心理学，以及我们如何欺骗大脑中的机制，让自己变得更快乐一点。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. Happiness is a paradox. The things that we expect will make us happy often don't. And many things that do make us happy are often not what we might have predicted. Psychologist Sonia Lobamirski studies these mismatches. She believes that by understanding how these mismatches come about, we can actually do things to increase our happiness and decrease our misery. Sonia, I want to start by unpacking some of the psychological drivers of these mismatches.
这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。幸福是一个悖论。我们预期会让我们快乐的事情往往不会。而许多确实让我们快乐的事情往往不是我们所预料到的。心理学家索尼娅·柳博米尔斯基研究这些错位。她相信，通过了解这些错位是如何产生的，我们实际上可以采取行动来增加我们的幸福感并减少我们的痛苦。索尼娅，我想从剖析这些错位的一些心理驱动因素开始。
And I want to start with perhaps the most important idea of all. Can you tell me what you mean by hedonic adaptation? Yes, hedonic adaptation is basically the phenomenon that human beings are remarkably good at getting used to changes in our lives, both positive changes and negative changes, although hedonic adaptation is faster to positive changes.
我想从也许最重要的想法开始。你能告诉我你所说的“享乐适应”是什么意思吗？是的，享乐适应基本上是一种现象，即人类非常擅长习惯我们生活中的变化，无论是积极的变化还是消极的变化，尽管享乐适应对积极变化的适应速度更快。
And when people sometimes talk about the hedonic treadmill, what do they mean by that phrase? What is the hedonic treadmill? Right, so the hedonic treadmill, so I think of the hedonic treadmill as basically hedonic adaptation in action. So there's really two, I guess, aspects of hed the adaptation that are really important is that what happens is when we, when we get the job that we want, when we get more money, have a new relationship that we really like that what happens after those positive changes is that our first expectations or aspirations change, right? So now, now when we live in the bigger house, you know, that becomes our new normal. And so now we think, well, maybe, you know, an extra bedroom would be even nicer, you know, or a deck would be nicer. I certainly have
当人们有时谈论“享乐跑步机”时，他们指的是什么？什么是享乐跑步机？对，所以享乐跑步机，我认为享乐跑步机基本上就是行动中的享乐适应。所以，我想享乐适应有两个方面非常重要，那就是当我们得到我们想要的工作，当我们得到更多的钱，有了我们真正喜欢的新关系时，在这些积极变化之后发生的事情是，我们最初的期望或抱负改变了，对吧？所以现在，当我们住进更大的房子时，你知道，那成了我们的新常态。所以现在我们想，嗯，也许，你知道，多一个卧室会更好，你知道，或者有一个露台会更好。我当然有
friends who are constantly talking about like improving their houses, even though their houses are perfectly beautiful and enormous. And the other thing that matters is our social comparisons change. So when we move into that bigger house than a new neighborhood, suddenly we notice our neighbors have houses that are might be even nicer than ours or drive cars that are nicer than ours. So there are social comparisons change, which also lead us to kind of want even more. So again, sort of the bottom line is, hedonic adaptation leads us to kind of want even more than we have. So we're never quite satisfied. And the idea of the treadmill, of course, is that you're walking, but it feels like you're staying in place. In fact, you've moved up in the world, but it feels emotionally, it feels like, you know,
朋友们一直在谈论改善他们的房子，尽管他们的房子已经非常漂亮且巨大了。另一件重要的事情是我们的社会比较改变了。所以当我们搬进那个比新社区更大的房子时，突然我们注意到我们的邻居拥有的房子可能比我们的更好，或者开的车比我们的更好。所以我们的社会比较改变了，这也导致我们想要更多。所以，归根结底，享乐适应导致我们想要比我们拥有的更多。所以我们永远不会完全满足。当然，“跑步机”的概念是，你在走，但感觉就像你在原地踏步。事实上，你在世界上已经进步了，但在情感上，感觉就像，你知道，
you are where you're used to be. Right. So they don't have treadmills kind of like, you're getting more stuff, you're getting more goals accomplished, but then you want even more than that. So you don't feel like you're any happier. And again, getting back to sort of evolutionary theory, you could argue that this is really good. This is the depth of the human beings are never quite satisfied. If we didn't have it on a adaptation, maybe we'd just be sort of complacent and we'd just sort of stop pursuing new things and all progress might stop, right? So it's kind of a good thing, but it's sort of not so good for our happiness. The Hedonic Adaptation also plays out at a societal level. As countries get wealthier and people can live in bigger homes and drive better cars,
你回到了你习惯的地方。对。所以享乐跑步机有点像，你得到了更多的东西，你实现了更多的目标，但随后你想要更多。所以你感觉不到自己更快乐了。再次回到进化论，你可以说这真的很好。这是人类永远不会完全满足的深度。如果我们没有享乐适应，也许我们只会变得自满，我们只会停止追求新事物，所有的进步都可能停止，对吧？所以这算是一件好事，但对我们的幸福来说却不是那么好。享乐适应也在社会层面发挥作用。随着国家变得更富裕，人们可以住进更大的房子，开更好的车，
they often don't end up feeling happier. Because our expectations can grow faster than our bank accounts, we can be much better off than people who lived 75 years ago. But feel worse. I mean, at this sort of specific level, you know, it used to be people would have like one car per household. Now we have two to three cars per household and people lived in smaller houses
他们往往最终并没有感到更快乐。因为我们的期望增长速度可能快于我们的银行账户，我们可能比75年前生活的人好得多。但感觉更糟。我的意思是，在这个特定的层面上，你知道，过去人们每户人家只有一辆车。现在我们每户人家有两到三辆车，人们住在更小的房子里
and think about our appliances, right? And, you know, I remember actually I grew up in Russia where we had to wash our clothes by hand. And that was a huge pain, but, you know, we didn't really think about it, because we didn't think about the alternative. And then, of course, now I can't imagine going back to not having a washing machine. Right. So, so yes, so we get, you know, our expectations change, and then kind of at a broader level, you know, there's some researches that show that, for example, you know, women are less, a little less satisfied than used to be. And it's likely because, you know, now, you know,
想想我们的电器，对吧？而且，你知道，我记得我实际上是在俄罗斯长大的，我们不得不手洗衣服。那真是太痛苦了，但是，你知道，我们并没有真正去想它，因为我们没有想到替代方案。然后，当然，现在我无法想象回到没有洗衣机的生活。对。所以，是的，所以我们得到，你知道，我们的期望改变了，然后在大一点的层面上，你知道，有一些研究表明，例如，你知道，女性比过去稍微不那么满意了。这很可能是因为，你知道，现在，你知道，
women feel like, you know, they're at least opportunities that they have and maybe they aren't able to sort of achieve all of those opportunities. Maybe they're still kind of have more responsibilities at home. Whereas it used to be their expectations were kind of lower. There wasn't really that alternative. And it's wonderful that we have all these new opportunities, but also means that our expectations keep constantly changing and rising and improving.
女性觉得，你知道，她们至少拥有机会，也许她们无法实现所有这些机会。也许她们在家里仍然承担更多的责任。而过去她们的期望比较低。并没有真正的替代方案。拥有所有这些新机会真是太棒了，但也意味着我们的期望不断地改变、上升和提高。
You once visited Google, which is the company that famously gives employees fabulous benefits. And you talked with some of the employees at Google about how much they were appreciating the things that they got at the company. What did people tell you? It was really cool. People brought their pets to work and they had game rooms and they had music rooms with guitars and drums and all kinds of snacks everywhere and really great food. And people were like, oh, the crab cakes again.
你曾经访问过谷歌，这家公司以给员工提供极好的福利而闻名。你和谷歌的一些员工谈论了他们对公司提供的福利有多么感激。人们告诉你什么？这真的很酷。人们带宠物上班，他们有游戏室，有带吉他和鼓的音乐室，到处都是各种零食，还有非常棒的食物。人们就像，哦，又是蟹饼。
You know, so they were already had adapted, right? And partly, you know, they don't go visit like other workplaces. And then, you know, one of my sort of advice is like, well, go visit other workplaces so you can kind of see that you have it better than others. But yeah, we just adapt so quickly. It's amazing to me.
你知道，所以他们已经适应了，对吧？而且部分原因，你知道，他们不去参观其他工作场所。然后，你知道，我的建议之一是，去参观其他工作场所，这样你就能看到你比别人过得更好。但是的，我们适应得太快了。这让我感到惊讶。
So I want to talk about these twin enemies. One is sort of a resentment about what we don't have. And the second is a sense of entitlement about what we do have. And so, for example, when it used to take weeks to basically make a transatlantic journey, and now you can make the journey in seven hours, and now people are like sitting in the airport saying, you know, how come my plane is 20 minutes late? Or why haven't we departed on time? So our capacity to be entitled to take for granted
所以我想谈谈这两个孪生敌人。一个是关于我们没有的东西的怨恨，第二个是关于我们拥有的东西的权利感。所以，例如，当跨大西洋旅行过去需要几周时间，而现在你可以在七小时内完成旅程时，人们坐在机场说，你知道，为什么我的飞机晚点了20分钟？或者为什么我们没有准时出发？所以我们认为理所当然的权利感
the things that we have, it's almost infinite. Yeah, it's kind of amazing. Actually, airplanes are a great example. I remember, I don't know when, but the very first time I flew business class in an airplane, it took me like five minutes to get used to the idea that now I'm like, this higher class citizen. And I remember it's looking at those poor souls, right?
我们拥有的东西，几乎是无限的。是的，这有点令人惊讶。事实上，飞机就是一个很好的例子。我记得，我不记得是什么时候了，我第一次坐飞机商务舱，我花了大约五分钟才习惯我现在是这种更高阶层公民的想法。我记得看着那些可怜的灵魂，对吧？
Who are like shuffling their way to the back of the airplane and feelings superior to them, right? And it's so easy and it's so fast that we become adapted to things and we feel entitled to them. We've talked a little bit about the role of adaptation in love and marriage, and you've talked a little bit about this in your own life, Sonia. When you were a children, what was your experience having children?
他们正拖着脚步走向飞机的后部，并感到优越于他们，对吧？我们变得适应事物并感到理所当然是如此容易和迅速。我们已经谈论了一点关于适应在爱情和婚姻中的作用，索尼娅，你已经在你自己的生活中谈论了一点。当你还是个孩子时，你有孩子是什么样的经历？
Was it different after you had one child? I mean, did you feel like you adapted very quickly to the idea of having one child and then wanted another? I hate to say it, but there is something really special about that first child, right? Because you could never have that experience again. And the thing is, yeah, yeah, I did adapt to having children. I ended up having four, believe it or not, but not 100%. And partly it's because they're always growing and changing.
生了一个孩子后有什么不同吗？我的意思是，你觉得你很快就适应了有一个孩子的想法，然后又想要另一个吗？我不想这么说，但第一个孩子确实有一些非常特别的地方，对吧？因为你永远无法再有那种经历了。问题是，是的，我确实适应了有孩子。信不信由你，我最终生了四个，但不是100%。部分原因是他们总是在成长和变化。
And we haven't talked about this, but we tend to adapt to constant stimuli, right? So you buy a car and then it's sort of the same car today as it is, you know, next week and next month, but children aren't the same, you know, in a month. And so we don't kind of adapt to them completely. And I do think there are a few things, like a few activities that we might do that we don't adapt to. And the one thing that I've never adapted to is cuddling with my kids, you know. I am so happy. I feel like I'm high when I'm cuddling with my kids. You know, I am so happy. I feel like I'm high when
我们还没有谈到这一点，但我们倾向于适应持续的刺激，对吧？所以你买了一辆车，然后它今天和下周、下个月是一样的，但孩子在一个月内是不一样的。所以我们并没有完全适应他们。我确实认为有一些活动是我们可能不会适应的。我从未适应的一件事是和我的孩子们拥抱，你知道。我太快乐了。我觉得我在和孩子们拥抱时就像飘飘欲仙。你知道，我太快乐了，我觉得我在
I'm cuddling with them. And I have two little ones now. And I've never adapted to that. So I think there are some, some sort of things that maybe to correct my old advisor, Lee Ross, all that they're all that I've cracked up to be, maybe not sex and tenure, but cuddling and Paris. I don't know. I'll have to rethink that about that. but cuddling in Paris. I don't know. I'll have to rethink about that. I want to focus on another area that we touched on a little bit earlier and I had to do with the role that evolution might play in prompting us to feel certain ways about certain things. So certainly when it comes to love, for example, the experience of infatuation, the experience of passionate love, as you point out,
和他们拥抱。我现在有两个小家伙。我从未适应过这一点。所以我认为有一些事情，也许是为了纠正我的老导师李·罗斯，所有那些名副其实的东西，也许不是性和终身教职，而是拥抱和巴黎。我不知道。我得重新考虑一下。但拥抱和巴黎。我不知道。我得重新考虑一下。我想关注我们之前稍微触及的另一个领域，这与进化可能在促使我们对某些事物产生某种感觉方面所起的作用有关。所以当然，当涉及到爱情时，例如，迷恋的经历，激情之爱的经历，正如你指出的那样，
it's designed in some ways where it's designed to experience these very strong emotions. But I'm wondering if you can talk a moment about the fact that when we experience these very strong emotions, they don't feel like they're transient. I think one of the reasons people often feel let down when passionate love retreats from their lives is because they feel when they're experiencing passionate love it feels as if it's going to last forever. Can you talk a little bit about the role that our instincts play and how wise we would be to trust or to mistrust our instincts in telling us what to do and when to be happy? It's an excellent point and it applies to lots of domains,
它在某种程度上被设计成体验这些非常强烈的情绪。但我很想知道你是否能谈谈这样一个事实：当我们体验这些非常强烈的情绪时，它们感觉并不像是短暂的。我认为人们在激情之爱从生活中消退时感到失望的原因之一是，因为他们觉得当他们体验激情之爱时，感觉它会永远持续下去。你能谈谈我们的本能所起的作用，以及我们在告诉自己该做什么和何时快乐时，信任或不信任我们的本能有多明智吗？这是一个极好的观点，它适用于许多领域，
right? So we're first in love. We can't imagine the passion fading. If I remember, I really should not talk to couples, but there's a couple that I was talking to who are really passionately in love and they're like, Sonya, don't tell us the passion fades and I'm like, well, because you just can't imagine it and maybe that's good, right?
对吧？所以我们第一次坠入爱河。我们无法想象激情会消退。如果我记得的话，我真的不应该和情侣们谈论这个，但我谈过的一对情侣，他们真的非常相爱，他们说，索尼娅，别告诉我们激情会消退，我说，嗯，因为你就是无法想象它，也许那是一件好事，对吧？
Because you wouldn't really be happy if you're constantly sort of thinking, oh, this is not going to last. Right. But, or like, imagine like when you're really hungry, you're not supposed to go shopping when you're like too hungry, right? Because you just can't sort of imagine like ever not being hungry, right?
因为如果你一直想“哦，这不会持续下去”，你就不会真正快乐。对吧。或者，想象一下当你真的很饿时，你不应该在太饿的时候去购物，对吧？因为你就是无法想象自己不再饥饿，对吧？
And it applies to lots of sort of states and lots of emotions. Or when we're miserable for that matter, when we're depressed, it's really hard to sort of think about like how I'll, you know, they'll come a time when I'm not going to feel this down. Another example, actually, this is one reason I actually started studying happiness is that I'm amazed at how how our mood can affect how we feel about everything, right? Once some days we wake up and we're just happy and everything's up to, and we're so optimistic and we feel good about ourselves, we just feel good about everything. And then other days we wake up and we feel kind of not so good about everything. And it's really hard to remind ourselves
它适用于许多状态和许多情绪。或者当我们痛苦时，当我们抑郁时，真的很难去想“会有我不感到这么低落的时候”。另一个例子，实际上，这是我开始研究幸福的原因之一，我对我们的情绪如何影响我们对一切的感觉感到惊讶，对吧？有些日子我们醒来，我们只是快乐，一切都很好，我们非常乐观，我们对自己感觉良好，我们对一切都感觉良好。然后其他日子我们醒来，我们对一切感觉都不太好。提醒自己真的很难
that like, no, I'm not going to feel this way forever. When we try and forecast whether something's going to make us happy or unhappy, you know, we're actually thinking about the thing. We're trying to imagine what would it be like to have perfect vision, or what would it be like to be a prince or a princess, or to get a great job, or to find a soulmate. We're ruminating on it in the present.
“不，我不会永远这样”。当我们试图预测某件事是否会让我们快乐或不快乐时，你知道，我们实际上是在思考那件事。我们试图想象拥有完美的视力会是什么样子，或者成为王子或王妃，或者得到一份很棒的工作，或者找到灵魂伴侣会是什么样子。我们在当下反复思考它。
Can you talk about the concept of present bias, and how the things that we're thinking about in some ways loom larger in our minds than they actually will in the future. Yeah, exactly. And so when we think about when we're forecasting sort of our future feelings, we're thinking about the change, right? And one of my favorite studies out of the University of Chicago, people got the news that they're going to get a kit guide bar and then they sort of anticipated eating it and then they ate it, consumed it,
你能谈谈“当下偏见”的概念，以及我们正在思考的事情在某种程度上在我们的脑海中比它们在未来实际发生时显得更重要吗？是的，完全正确。所以当我们思考预测我们未来的感受时，我们是在思考变化，对吧？我最喜欢的一项来自芝加哥大学的研究，人们得到了他们将得到一根奇巧巧克力棒的消息，然后他们预料到吃它，然后他们吃了它，消费了它，
and then they would call it. And similar studies have been done with like vacations, right? Imagine being told you're gonna go to Venice, you know, and then now anticipated, now go to Venice, now recall it. And in some of the studies show that the biggest impact on your happiness is during the news part, right? Like when you first learn, oh, you get to go to Venice, I get to have this chocolate bar more than the anticipation also more than the concern of the consumption or the recall the recollection of it. I want to talk about another psychological driver of the mismatch between our expectations and reality and that is we often don't respond with proportion to the annoyances and irritants in daily life. Sonya you had a couple of experiences in close proximity to one another,
然后他们会回顾它。类似的关于假期的研究也做过，对吧？想象被告知你要去威尼斯，你知道，然后现在预料它，现在去威尼斯，现在回顾它。一些研究表明，对你幸福影响最大的是“新闻”部分，对吧？就像当你第一次得知，哦，你可以去威尼斯，我可以得到这块巧克力棒，这比期待，也比消费的关注或对它的回忆更重要。我想谈谈期望与现实之间错位的另一个心理驱动因素，那就是我们往往对日常生活中的烦恼和刺激反应不成比例。索尼娅，你在很短的时间内有过几次经历，
one of which you could classify as a minor irritant and the other was much more serious. Can you tell me about these two incidents and what you learned about yourself from them? You know, I actually had these two bad experiences on the same day. I had a long reserve window seat on a really long flight and it was taken away from me.
其中一个你可以归类为轻微的刺激，另一个则严重得多。你能告诉我这两起事件以及你从中学到了关于自己的什么吗？你知道，我实际上在同一天经历了这两次糟糕的经历。我在一次长途飞行中有一个长预留靠窗座位，它被取消了。
So then I had to sit in the middle and I was really unhappy about that. But then the same day, I got into a really bad car accident on the freeway. I mean, I wasn't heard, but my car was completely totaled and it was kind of traumatic. And what was incredible is that when I had the car accident, I actually was like really calm and cool headed.
所以我不得不坐在中间，我对此非常不高兴。但同一天，我在高速公路上发生了一场非常严重的撞车事故。我的意思是，我没有受伤，但我的车完全报废了，这有点创伤性。令人难以置信的是，当我发生车祸时，我实际上非常冷静和头脑清醒。
And I sort of knew what I had to do. I didn't panic. And it's kind of amazing to me how sometimes when, you know, really big and bad things happen, we are sort of less upset in the moment. Maybe because, you know, we're kind of mustering all the resources that we have to cope with the situation. Whereas when kind of little hassles happen to us,
我知道我必须做什么。我没有惊慌。有时当真正重大和糟糕的事情发生时，我们在那一刻反而不那么难过，这让我感到惊讶。也许是因为，你知道，我们正在调动我们所有的资源来应对这种情况。而当一些小麻烦发生在我们身上时，
we get angry and we get stressed out. I think it's a profound insight that you had here, Sonia, because I feel like all of us have had this experience and you hear this all the time when there are major calamities happening, ordinary people act with great heroism and poise. And yet you also see people reacting with over you know, over the top annoyance and frustration at totally trivial things. And I think there's something here that's not just, you know, in your mind,
我们变得愤怒和压力很大。我认为这是一个深刻的见解，索尼娅，因为我觉得我们所有人都经历过这种情况，当你听到重大灾难发生时，你会一直听到这种说法，普通人表现出极大的英雄主义和镇定。然而，你也看到人们对完全琐碎的事情表现出过度的烦恼和沮丧。我认为这里有一些不仅仅是，你知道，在你脑海中的东西，
but really something that's more generalizable to how human beings think about minor and major irritants. I agree. And I think partly it has to do with the stories that we tell about these events where with the really big thing, we kind of, you thing, we take pains to make sense of it, to look on the bright side, maybe to rationalize it, what we've learned from it. And the little things are really kind of hard to rationalize. So I lost my window seat. And I'm not gonna go convince me with my friends about that,
但实际上，这更适用于人类如何看待大大小小的烦恼。我同意。我认为这在一定程度上与我们讲述这些事件的方式有关，对于真正重大的事情，我们会费尽心思去理解它，去寻找光明的一面，也许还会去合理化它，去思考我们从中吸取了什么教训。而小事却很难合理化。比如我失去了靠窗的座位，我不会去和朋友们争论这件事，
or they'll be bored, or be like, wow, your life is boring. But then I could get the social support, you know, for the car accident. Right. So we all know people who are simply happy. Bad stuff happens to them, but they bounce back. We also know people who are mostly unhappy. Good things happen to them. And you know, they might have a brief blip of joy, and then they go back to feeling morose about their lives Can you talk about the role of happiness set points as one of the psychological drivers between the mismatch Between our expectations and reality sure, you know Well, we all know that some people are happier than others
否则他们会觉得无聊，或者觉得你的生活真乏味。但对于车祸，我却能得到社会支持。没错。所以我们都认识一些天生快乐的人。即使发生坏事，他们也能很快恢复。我们也认识一些大多时候都不快乐的人。即使发生好事，他们可能只会短暂地感到一阵喜悦，然后又回到对生活郁郁寡欢的状态。你能谈谈幸福设定点作为我们期望与现实之间不匹配的心理驱动因素之一的作用吗？当然，你知道，我们都知道有些人比其他人更快乐。
This is actually how my research in happiness started in grad school and my advisor and I started talking about like Why are some people happier than others? There's almost a resentful edge to that question, Sonia. Yeah, it sounds like it, right? But again, I'm a pretty happy person, but I'm still interested in that question. There's clearly, you know, there's evidence that the genetic influences on happiness. And anyone who has more than one child can attest, you feel like you're kind of raising them in a similar environment and yet some of your kids are probably a lot happier than others.
这其实就是我在研究生院开始幸福研究的方式，我和导师开始讨论为什么有些人比其他人更快乐。索尼娅，这个问题里几乎带有一种怨恨的意味。是的，听起来确实是这样，对吧？但再说一次，我是一个相当快乐的人，但我仍然对这个问题很感兴趣。显然，有证据表明遗传对幸福有影响。任何有不止一个孩子的人都可以证明，你觉得你是在相似的环境中抚养他们，但其中一些孩子可能比其他人快乐得多。
You know, they get much more distressed by the same kind of event, you know, one kid more than another. And so that does play a role that happier people are kind of, quote, luckier in a sense that they're kind of naturally, more grateful and optimistic, and more resilient than people who are less happy. So yeah, that's clearly one of the drivers and how we respond to major changes in our lives. But isn't it also a source of the mismatch? Because for example, if my happiness levels
你知道，他们会对同样的事件感到更加痛苦，一个孩子比另一个更甚。所以这确实起到了作用，更快乐的人在某种意义上更“幸运”，因为他们天生就更感恩、更乐观，也比那些不那么快乐的人更有韧性。所以是的，这显然是驱动因素之一，也影响了我们如何应对生活中的重大变化。但难道这不也是不匹配的根源吗？因为例如，如果我的幸福水平
are actually set at a certain level, or in other words, I have some ability to change them up or down, let's say 10%, 15%, 20%, but I don't have the ability to change it by 70%. But I imagine, if I get the relationship that I want, if I get the job that I want, if I can move to the city that I want, I can become a radically different person who is entirely different in terms of happiness. But in fact, if my set point of happiness is fixed at a certain level, this might be why there's a mismatch between my expectations and reality.
实际上设定在某个水平，或者换句话说，我有能力将其上下调整，比如说10%、15%、20%，但我没有能力将其改变70%。但我会想象，如果我得到了我想要的感情，如果我得到了我想要的工作，如果我能搬到我想要的城市，我就能成为一个截然不同的人，在幸福感方面完全不同。但事实上，如果我的幸福设定点固定在某个水平，这可能就是为什么我的期望与现实之间存在不匹配的原因。
Right. Well, first let me state that if you live in a war zone in Syria or you're in an abusive relationship or you're very poor, then absolutely the environment can change in ways to make you a lot happier. But let's say most of the listeners to this program are, you know, maybe have, you know, fairly comfortable lives so that, you know, they're not, you know, very, very poor. They're not in a war zone. So in that situation, yes, they can become happier, but and probably not hugely, hugely happier. But one of my favorite kind of ways to think about this comes from, I think it was dear Abby actually, where someone
没错。好吧，首先让我声明，如果你生活在叙利亚的战区，或者处于一段虐待关系中，或者非常贫穷，那么环境绝对可以改变，让你变得快乐得多。但假设这个节目的大多数听众，你知道，可能过着相当舒适的生活，所以他们并不非常贫穷，也不在战区。在这种情况下，是的，他们可以变得更快乐，但可能不会变得非常非常快乐。但我最喜欢的一种思考方式来自亲爱的艾比（Dear Abby），当时有人
wrote a letter to her said, like, oh, I have this job and I don't like it. So then I moved to this other job and I thought that would be better, but I don't like that one either. I hate my boss and I went to the third job and, you know, sort of on and on. And Abby said, you know, it's not the job. It's you, right? You're the same person moving from one job to the other, but that can happen in the positive side as well. Another driver in the mismatch between our happiness and our expectations is not inside our own heads, but in our culture. One of the reasons that became interesting happiness is that when I moved to the US, where I was almost 10 years old, I noticed how different Americans were.
写信给她说，哦，我有这份工作，我不喜欢它。所以我换了另一份工作，我以为会更好，但我也不喜欢那份工作。我讨厌我的老板，于是我去了第三份工作，等等。艾比说，你知道，不是工作的问题，是你，对吧？你是同一个人从一份工作换到另一份工作，但这在积极的一面也会发生。我们幸福感与期望之间不匹配的另一个驱动因素不在我们自己的脑海中，而是在我们的文化中。我之所以对幸福产生兴趣，原因之一是我搬到美国时，我快10岁了，我注意到美国人是多么不同。
So Americans would walk down the street and they would smile at you and they would say, hi, and Russians don't really do that in the street. On the other hand, I noticed differences that are kind of public versus private, right? So when you go to dinner in a Russian home, this is kind of a stereotype, but it's really true. People are drinking and they're singing and they're laughing and telling jokes. And I remember the first time that I was invited
所以美国人走在街上会向你微笑，会说“嗨”，而俄罗斯人在街上真的不会那样做。另一方面，我注意到了一些公共与私人之间的差异，对吧？所以当你去俄罗斯人家里吃晚饭时，这是一种刻板印象，但确实是真的。人们喝酒、唱歌、大笑、讲笑话。我记得我第一次被邀请
to dinner at a friend's house in Washington DC where I grew up. And people were just sitting kind of like very seriously around the table kind of like saying, can you pass the salt please, right? And I thought like, wow, they don't seem very happy. And again, this doesn't mean that they're not happy, but I became interested in these sort of these cultural differences.
去我在华盛顿特区长大的朋友家吃晚饭。人们只是非常严肃地坐在桌子旁，说着“请把盐递给我，好吗？”，对吧？我想，哇，他们看起来不太快乐。再说一次，这并不意味着他们不快乐，但我开始对这些文化差异产生了兴趣。
Yeah. I'm wondering though, is it possible that certain cultural contexts change our standards of what, of what, how happy we should be because there are some cultural contexts that say that happiness is a right. I mean the pursuit of happiness is actually literally enshrined in the US Declaration of Independence. There are very few other countries that whose founding documents say that the pursuit of happiness is a worthwhile goal. And I'm wondering does that change the way we think? On the one hand, it probably prompts people to actually seek happiness in other places
是的。不过我在想，某些文化背景是否会改变我们对应该有多快乐的标准，因为有些文化背景认为幸福是一种权利。我的意思是，追求幸福实际上被写进了美国《独立宣言》。很少有其他国家的建国文件说追求幸福是一个值得的目标。我在想，这是否改变了我们的思维方式？一方面，它可能会促使人们在其他地方寻求幸福，
they might be more resigned to wherever they are. But it also potentially makes people more unhappy because you're constantly asking, how can I be happier than what I am right now? Exactly. So I think in the US and in Western culture, there is much more of a kind of a focus or maybe a preoccupation with happiness
他们可能对现状更加顺从。但这也有可能使人们更加不快乐，因为你不断地问，我怎样才能比现在更快乐？没错。所以我认为在美国和西方文化中，确实有更多的一种关注，或者说对幸福的执着，
that I can actually backfire, right? That can lead to some unhappiness. On the other hand, even in Russia, like it's funny, there's this focus on, you know, in Russia, people talk about the importance of suffering, right? Suffering, you know, is important because it builds character and it might help you gain salvation in the next life. But when I went back actually years ago in the 90s and I asked people, what do you want most for your children?
这实际上可能会适得其反，对吧？这可能会导致一些不快乐。另一方面，即使在俄罗斯，这很有趣，人们关注的是，你知道，在俄罗斯，人们谈论苦难的重要性，对吧？苦难很重要，因为它能塑造性格，可能有助于你在来世获得救赎。但当我在90年代回到那里，问人们最希望孩子得到什么时，
And Russian parents said, I want my children to be happy. So I do think that happiness is a fairly universal goal, but how we pursue it differs. And I guess how important it is does differ, because there is more of a obsession with happiness in our culture. Our perceptions, predictions, and expectations about happiness are often flawed. A shiny prize is supposed to make us happy, but when it doesn't, we immediately start looking for the next shiny object.
俄罗斯父母说，我希望我的孩子快乐。所以我确实认为幸福是一个相当普遍的目标，但我们追求它的方式不同。我想它有多重要确实有所不同，因为我们的文化中对幸福有一种痴迷。我们对幸福的感知、预测和期望往往是有缺陷的。一个闪亮的奖品本应让我们快乐，但当它没有时，我们立即开始寻找下一个闪亮的目标。
Where we come back, how to break that cycle and use psychology to crack the happiness code? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We all want to be happy, but finding happiness isn't as straightforward as it looks. Sometimes marrying a prince or getting the riches you desire does not make you happy. And sometimes things you might not have predicted would make you happy bring a big smile to your face. Sonya Lubamirski is a psychologist who has spent years studying these mismatches but also looking for ways to crack the happiness code. these mismatches, but also looking for ways to crack the happiness code. So you and your husband did not live together before you got married.
回来后，我们将探讨如何打破这种循环，并利用心理学破解幸福密码。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们都想快乐，但寻找幸福并不像看起来那么简单。有时嫁给王子或获得你渴望的财富并不能让你快乐。有时你可能没预料到会让你快乐的事情却能让你脸上露出灿烂的笑容。索尼娅·柳博米尔斯基是一位心理学家，她花了多年时间研究这些不匹配，同时也寻找破解幸福密码的方法。这些不匹配，同时也寻找破解幸福密码的方法。所以你和你的丈夫在结婚前没有住在一起。
And much later in your research, you realized that you may have unintentionally done something that was psychologically smart. Now you're not making a puritanical argument here about how people should behave in their private lives, but getting at an important insight about how our minds work. Can you tell me what you found in your personal life and how this was reflected by your research? Absolutely. I mean, we've been talking about how quickly we adapt
在后来的研究中，你意识到你可能无意中做了一件心理上很聪明的事情。现在你不是在这里发表关于人们应该如何在私生活中表现的清教徒式论点，而是要得出一个关于我们大脑如何运作的重要见解。你能告诉我你在个人生活中发现了什么，以及这如何反映在你的研究中吗？当然。我的意思是，我们一直在谈论我们适应
to positive changes in our lives. And when we fall in love, I remember falling in love with my husband and I really wanted to spend all my time with him. And I wanted to move in with him before we got married. But he, not for any kind of moral or religious reason, he just thought like, you know, it would be like better if we wait until, you know, we just, we'd be happier if we waited until we got married and we got married, you know, maybe a year later. And then when we did move in together, it was so
生活中的积极变化有多快。当我们坠入爱河时，我记得我爱上了我的丈夫，我真的想和他共度所有时间。我想在结婚前和他住在一起。但他，不是出于任何道德或宗教原因，他只是觉得，你知道，如果我们等到结婚后再住在一起会更好，我们会更快乐，我们结婚了，你知道，可能是一年后。然后当我们真的住在一起时，那真是
wonderful. Then it made getting married so much more special, you know, I hate to admit it, but now of course we have adapted to living together after 23 years and in fact during the pandemic, you know, I would tell him like Pete his name is Peter like can you please leave the house for like Maybe three four five hours like he's he never left the house. I was never alone But you know, we I love him, but I just don't want to see him like 24 hours a day So there are different things you could do to try to kind of stave off that adaptation. Or one of them for us was not moving in together until
太美妙了。这让结婚变得更加特别，你知道，我不想承认，但现在当然，23年后我们已经适应了住在一起，事实上在疫情期间，你知道，我会告诉他，比如皮特，他的名字叫彼得，你能离开家三、四、五个小时吗？他从不离开家。我从来没有独处过。但你知道，我爱他，但我只是不想一天24小时见到他。所以你可以做不同的事情来试图抵御这种适应。或者对我们来说，其中之一就是直到
after the wedding. So there's an important insight here in some ways, which is that if you have positive experiences, obviously the thing we want to do is to keep those positive experiences going, we never want them to stop, we want to enjoy them more and more. But the paradox is, of course, when we do that, we start to adapt to them, we get used to them, and then they lose their pleasure, they lose the joy that they used to give us. And so one solution, it might seem a little difficult, but in some ways, you came up with this solution inadvertently, I think, before you got married. In some ways, it's to limit how much you're enjoying the thing that is giving you pleasure.
婚礼后才住在一起。所以这里有一个重要的见解，在某种程度上，如果你有积极的经历，显然我们想做的是让这些积极的经历持续下去，我们永远不想让它们停止，我们想更多地享受它们。但悖论当然是，当我们这样做时，我们开始适应它们，我们习惯了它们，然后它们失去了乐趣，失去了它们曾经带给我们的快乐。所以一个解决方案，看起来可能有点困难，但在某些方面，我认为你在结婚前无意中想出了这个解决方案。在某些方面，它是限制你享受给你带来快乐的事物的程度。
That in some ways, if you could bank your happiness to, sort of, say, this happiness awaits me, but I'm actually going to postpone it by just a little bit, you can draw out the happiness a little longer. Can you talk about this idea, Sonya? Yeah, exactly. It's kind of scarcity and limiting your experience. It's going to make you happier. I guess a really good example is eating out
在某些方面，如果你能储存你的幸福，说，这种幸福在等待着我，但我实际上要把它推迟一点点，你就能把幸福延长一点。你能谈谈这个想法吗，索尼娅？是的，完全正确。这是一种稀缺性，限制你的体验。这会让你更快乐。我想一个很好的例子是外出
at your favorite restaurant. You know, listen to your favorite song, right? Like, you just don't want to do that too often because then you'll become more monotonous. It'll become less interesting, less enjoyable. Yeah, and during the pandemic, I think all of us have had this experience of things that would routine to us before the pandemic became extremely rare during the pandemic, going out to a restaurant or meeting with friends or sitting at a coffee shop or giving some
去你最喜欢的餐厅。你知道，听你最喜欢的歌，对吧？你只是不想太频繁地这样做，因为那样会变得单调。它会变得不那么有趣，不那么令人愉快。是的，在疫情期间，我想我们所有人都经历过疫情前对我们来说是例行公事的事情在疫情期间变得极其罕见，去餐厅或与朋友见面或坐在咖啡店或给某人
on a hug. And suddenly we realized, oh my God, these things actually are incredibly valuable. And when we saw people meeting each other after a long time or hugging one another or sitting down at a restaurant together, we suddenly were struck by how powerful this was. But of course it took the external force of a pandemic in some ways to induce that scarcity in our lives.
一个拥抱。突然我们意识到，天哪，这些事情实际上是极其宝贵的。当我们看到人们在很长一段时间后见面或拥抱彼此或一起坐在餐厅里时，我们突然被这有多强大所震撼。但当然，在某种程度上，需要疫情的外部力量来诱导我们生活中的这种稀缺性。
Exactly. And I hate to say it, but I think after it's over, we may very well just go right back to what we were before and take those things for granted. Hopefully we've learned a lesson to try not to take them for granted and to introduce that scarcity into our lives and variety as well. Again, if you do the same thing once a week or every day,
没错。我不想这么说，但我认为在它结束后，我们很可能会回到以前的状态，把这些事情视为理所当然。希望我们吸取了教训，尽量不要把它们视为理所当然，并将这种稀缺性和多样性引入我们的生活中。再说一次，如果你每周或每天做同样的事情，
you're not going to get as much pleasure out of it. There is a less painful way to acquire the benefits of scarcity in our lives. Instead of foregoing pleasure or delaying it or having the joys in our lives robbed by disaster or tragedy, you can use your imagination to visualize what it would be like to not have that particular source of happiness in your life. Oh yes, oh my God, yes exactly. Or the counterfactual, what if you didn't have the thing, but I think that idea that life is impermanent, right, that things are not lasting.
你从中获得的快乐就不会那么多。有一种不那么痛苦的方法来获得生活中稀缺性的好处。与其放弃快乐或推迟它，或者让灾难或悲剧夺走我们生活中的快乐，你可以利用你的想象力来想象如果你的生活中没有那种特定的幸福来源会是什么样子。哦，是的，天哪，是的，完全正确。或者反事实，如果你没有那东西会怎样，但我认为生命是无常的，对吧，事物不会持久。
That's what gives everything kind of this bittersweet flavor, and also allows us to savor, right? And so one of the most common ways to, I think it try to enjoy something is to think like this is the last time. One of my favorite quotes from the movie Casablanca is like, kiss me, kiss me like it's the last time, right? So that really makes you kind of really enjoy
这就是赋予一切苦乐参半的味道，也让我们能够细细品味，对吧？所以，我认为尝试享受某事最常见的方法之一是想“这是最后一次”。我最喜欢的电影《卡萨布兰卡》中的一句台词是：“吻我，吻我，就像这是最后一次”，对吧？所以这真的让你以一种你不会有的方式去真正享受
and savor that kiss in a way that you won't. If you know, you can kiss 100 more times, you know, next week. Yeah, and this goes back to the employees we talked about at companies that give you fancy lunches and do your dry cleaning for you. It might be helpful to spend a day a week or a day a month at another company, which does not give you those kinds of things, so that you can better appreciate what it is that you have. Or that company shouldn't just throw a fire hose of goodies at you every day, but somehow limit them and intermittently sprinkle them. Crab cakes only on special days, not every day. But isn't it ironic, Sonya, that the impulse that we have, you know, when something gives
和品味那个吻。如果你知道下周你还可以吻100次，你知道。是的，这回到了我们谈到的那些为员工提供精美午餐并为你干洗衣服的公司。每周或每月花一天时间在另一家不提供这些东西的公司工作可能会有帮助，这样你就能更好地欣赏你所拥有的东西。或者那家公司不应该每天都向你喷洒好东西，而应该以某种方式限制它们，并间歇性地撒播。蟹饼只在特殊的日子提供，而不是每天。但索尼娅，讽刺的是，当我们某样东西给我们
us pleasure, we want more of it. And in some ways, it's almost counterintuitive to say that we actually want to hold this pleasurable thing at bay to some extent in order to draw out the happiness we can derive from it. Exactly. Another example is a, in a new relationship where you become more and more intimate, like you kind of reveal more and more of yourself to the other person. And it's so pleasurable, right? Because you're like, you get to know them better. And some couples just kind of like, they just do it too fast, you know? They just sort of tell
带来快乐时，我们想要更多。在某种程度上，说我们实际上想要在一定程度上抑制这种令人愉悦的事物，以便提取我们可以从中获得的幸福，这几乎是违反直觉的。完全正确。另一个例子是在一段新的关系中，你变得越来越亲密，你向对方展示了越来越多的自己。这太令人愉快了，对吧？因为你觉得，你更了解他们了。有些情侣只是，你知道，他们做得太快了，你知道？他们只是在最初的，你知道，两周内
each other everything in the first, you know, two weeks. And, you know, and then there's like not very much left. So, and so I tell young people to kind of like, go slower, right? Like, allow that intimacy building to last longer. We've looked at ways we can extend happiness and make it last longer. In her book, The Myths of Happiness, Sony has also studied techniques to limit unhappiness, or at least to make it end more quickly. One of them put down negative experiences in a journal. So writing kind of forces you to kind of think about your life of experiences in a kind of a systematic way, like kind of what causes what. And so it helps you process those experiences.
告诉对方一切。然后，你知道，就没有剩下多少了。所以，我告诉年轻人要慢一点，对吧？让那种亲密感的建立持续更久。我们已经研究了可以延长幸福并使其持续更久的方法。在她的书《幸福的神话》中，索尼娅还研究了限制不快乐的技术，或者至少让它更快结束。其中之一是将负面经历写在日记中。所以写作迫使你以一种系统的方式思考你的生活经历，比如什么导致了什么。所以它帮助你处理这些经历。
So we have some studies that have shown that it's helpful or it makes people happier when they write about negative experiences, but not positive experiences. So positive experiences, you don't want to kind of like, try to explain or process, right? Or systematically analyze, you wanna just kind of like, let them happen. And so there's sort of this little bit of a symmetry where you kind of wanna write about negative things
所以我们有一些研究表明，当人们写下负面经历时，这很有帮助，或者让人更快乐，但写下积极经历则不然。所以积极的经历，你不想试图解释或处理，对吧？或者系统地分析，你只想让它们发生。所以这里有一点不对称，你想要写下负面事情
to get past them, but not write about, or kind of like sort of not really analyze positive things. Think about your happiest day and you don't want to analyze it. Like, oh, why did that happen? And why do I feel so good? That makes the happiness go away. Can you talk a little bit about the role of social interactions as an important ingredient
来克服它们，但不要写下，或者说不要真正分析积极的事情。想想你最快乐的一天，你不想分析它。比如，哦，为什么会发生这种情况？为什么我感觉这么好？这会让幸福消失。你能谈谈社交互动作为日常幸福的重要组成部分的作用吗？
for day to day happiness? We talked about sleep earlier on as one of those things where you notice it when you don't have it. But can you talk about the similar role that social interactions play in our day to day well-being? Yeah, social interaction, social connection, I think is what makes life worth living. And I'm doing quite a bit research on that, but basically people are happier when they're interacting with others, interventions that have instructed people
我们之前谈到了睡眠，当你没有它时你会注意到它。但你能谈谈社交互动在我们的日常幸福中扮演的类似角色吗？是的，社交互动，社会联系，我认为是让生活值得活下去的原因。我正在做相当多的研究，但基本上人们在与他人互动时更快乐，那些指导人们
to sort of interact more with others on a daily basis. They show that people become happier when they're more socially engaged. And so connection really is critical, although it can be very different kinds of connection. It could be with your pet. It could be with one person. It could be with your pet. It could be with one person. It could be with many people.
在日常生活中与他人更多互动的干预措施表明，当人们更积极地参与社交时，他们会变得更快乐。所以联系确实至关重要，尽管它可以是截然不同的联系。它可以是与你的宠物。它可以是一个人。它可以是与你的宠物。它可以是一个人。它可以是许多人。
It could be, you know, with close family versus equates as a stranger. So there's different kinds of connection that can make people happy. Hmm. Sonia, modern psychology has found again and again that happiness comes not just from doing the right things but doing them for the right reasons.
它可以是，你知道，与亲密的家人相比，与陌生人平等。所以有不同种类的联系可以让人们快乐。嗯。索尼娅，现代心理学一次又一次地发现，幸福不仅来自做正确的事情，还来自出于正确的原因去做这些事情。
I want to play you a bit of a commencement speech at the University of Houston. This is from the actor Matthew McConaughey, who is talking about an important change he made in his priorities. I started enjoying my work and literally being more happy. When I stopped trying to make the daily daily labor a means to a certain end. For example, I need this film to be a box office success. I need my performance to be acknowledged. I need the respect of my peers. All those are reasonable aspirations, but the truth is as soon as the work, the daily making of the movie, the doing of the deed became the reward in itself for me. I got more box office, more accolades, and respect than I ever had before.
我想给你播放一段马修·麦康纳在休斯顿大学的毕业演讲。这位演员谈到了他在优先事项上做出的一个重要改变。我开始享受我的工作，并真正变得更快乐。当我不再试图让日常劳动成为某种目的的手段时。例如，我需要这部电影在票房上取得成功。我需要我的表演得到认可。我需要同行的尊重。所有这些都是合理的愿望，但事实是，一旦工作，电影的日常制作，行为本身对我来说就成了奖励。我获得了比以往任何时候都多的票房、赞誉和尊重。
Can you talk a moment about this idea, Sonya, the difference between intrinsic motivation and extrinsic motivation and whether it has anything to do with the conversation we're having here about happiness? Yes, I was just going to say intrinsic goals. So when you do something just for the sake of the pleasure of doing it, the satisfaction of doing the fulfillment of doing it, you're going to be more creative, you're going to be more productive, you're going to do better, as opposed to, I'm just doing this to get an A in a class or, you know, to get a certain number of like, widgets sold. And so, so, absolutely, I think the interest of goals are really important. And this also gets back to what we're talking about before about the importance of sort
你能谈谈这个想法吗，索尼娅，内在动机和外在动机之间的区别，以及它是否与我们在这里谈论的关于幸福的对话有任何关系？是的，我正要说内在目标。所以当你仅仅为了做这件事的乐趣、满足感、成就感而做某事时，你会更有创造力，你会更有生产力，你会做得更好，而不是，我做这个只是为了在课堂上得A，或者，你知道，为了卖出一定数量的小玩意。所以，绝对地，我认为内在目标真的很重要。这也回到了我们之前谈到的关于到达那里的旅程的重要性，追求目标，而不是目标实现时的最终状态。所以现在我在想，你知道，心理学家是否谈论过他们所谓的“感恩练习”的重要性。感恩练习在某种程度上是否可能成为对抗享乐适应的防御手段？完全正确。我认为感恩是享乐适应的完美解药。当你想到享乐适应时，当你适应了生活中积极的事情时，这意味着你基本上把它视为理所当然。当你试图为你生活中的事物感恩时，
of the journey of getting there, of pursuing the goal as opposed to sort of the end goal in the state that will be when the goal is accomplished. So now I'm wondering whether you know, psychologists have talked about the importance of what they call a gratitude practice. Is it possible that a gratitude practice in some ways can be a defense against hedonic adaptation? Exactly. I think of gratitude as the perfect antidote to hedonic adaptation. When you think about hedonic adaptation, when you've adapted to something positive in your life, that means that you have essentially taken it for granted. And when you try to be grateful for the things in your life,
无论是你的健康、你的机会、你的工作还是你的家人，你基本上是在试图不把它们视为理所当然。你是在某种程度上中和那种适应。这可以在许多不同的领域发生，无论是关于你的工作、你的家人还是过去的经历。我曾经有过一段非常悲惨的童年和悲惨的青春期。所以当我离家去上大学时，那真是太棒了。所以，那段负面经历并没有让我受到创伤并产生负面影响，我反而感到非常快乐和感激，因为它结束了。我仍然
whether it's your health or your opportunities or your job or your family, you're basically trying not to take them for granted. You're sort of neutralizing that adaptation. And that could happen lots of different domains, whether it's about your job or your family or about past experiences. I had an experience where I had a really miserable childhood and miserable adolescence. And so when I left home to go to college, it was so amazing. So instead of that negative experience being sort of traumatizing and affecting me negatively, I was so happy and so grateful that it was over. I still
有时会想到这一点。我仍然很高兴我不再是青少年了。所以我认为感恩可以非常强大。我记得和丹·吉尔伯特交谈过，他也研究幸福科学多年，我记得几年前问过他，他是否因为做了所有这些研究而成为了一个更快乐的人，然后他告诉我，你知道，他并没有成为一个更快乐的人。他说我还是像以前一样不快乐。我只是知道我为什么不快乐。我在想这对你来说是否也是真的，索尼娅。你真的从你的研究中学到了如何变得更快乐吗？我喜欢丹的那句话。再说一次，我是一个相当
think about that sometimes. I'm still happy that I'm not an adolescent anymore. So I think gratitude can be very powerful. I remember speaking with Dan Gilbert, who has also studied the science of happiness for many years and I remember asking him some years ago whether he was a happier person as a result of doing all this research and and then told me that you know he wasn't a happier person. He said I'm just as unhappy as I used to be. I just know why I'm unhappy. I'm wondering if that's that's true for you as well, Sonia. Have you actually learned from your research to become happier? I love that quote from Dan. And again, I'm a fairly
快乐的人，但这并不意味着我总是做正确的事情来变得快乐。我的第一本书叫《幸福的方法》，我在书中谈到了12种让人们更快乐的不同策略。我仍然记得我写的每一章，我都对那种特定的练习变得痴迷，无论是做善事。所以我写那一章时，我开始想，哦，我今天应该为我的丈夫做些善事。或者我最喜欢的策略之一是品味。品味基本上是从一种体验中提取
happy person to begin with, but it doesn't mean that I'm always doing kind of the right things to be happy. My first book is called The Health Happiness, where I talked about 12 different strategies to make people happier. And I still remember that every chapter that I wrote, I kind of became obsessed with sort of that particular practice, whether it's sort of doing acts of kindness. So I was writing that chapter and then I started thinking, like, oh, I should do some acts of kindness for my husband today. Or one of my favorite strategies is savoring. And savoring is basically extracting kind
最大程度的享受。所以我写那一章时，真的在思考我如何能品味当下。因为有时，你知道，我们太忙了，我和孩子们在一起，而不是享受和孩子们在一起的时间，我在想我明天必须做什么，对吧？我的待办事项清单，而不是品味那段时间。所以，你知道，做幸福研究本质上就像是一个日常提醒，提醒我们为了快乐可以做些什么。有时我实际上会服用我自己的药，
of the maximum enjoyment out of an experience. And so I was writing that chapter and really thinking a lot about how I could savor the moment. Because sometimes, you know, we're so busy and I'd be with my kids and instead of enjoying my time with the kids, I'm thinking about what I have to do tomorrow, right? My to-do list instead of sort of savoring that time. And so, you know, doing research on happiness essentially is like a daily reminder of the kinds of things that we could be doing to be happy. And sometimes I actually take my own medicine
我做了那些事情。正如我们所见，享乐适应会夺走我们的幸福。但当困难时期到来时，它也可以对我们有利。你对发生在你身上的挫折的感觉，很少是你两周、两个月或两年后对它的感觉。有时看起来像灾难的事情实际上并不是灾难。索尼娅喜欢一个关于这个想法的来自中国古代的寓言。这是一个关于一个住在贫穷小村庄里的老农夫的非常美妙的小故事，但他拥有一匹马，所以他比邻居们幸运，他们认为他太幸运了。
and I do those things. As we've seen, hedonic adaptation can rob us of happiness. But it can also work in our favor when times are bad. How you feel about a setback that happens to you is rarely how you will feel about it after two weeks, or two months, or two years. It's also the case that sometimes things that appear like disasters are not in fact disasters. Sonia likes a parable about this idea from ancient China. It's a really wonderful little story about an old farmer who lived in a poor little country village, but he owned a horse, so he was sort of luckier than his neighbors, and they thought that he was so lucky.
但有一天他心爱的马跑了，听到这个消息后，他的邻居们想，哦，真是倒霉。但后来马回来了，它带回了六匹野马。所以突然间他又幸运了。他的邻居们嫉妒他。但后来他的儿子骑了一匹野马，摔断了腿。
But one day his beloved horse ran away, and so upon hearing that, his neighbors thought, oh, such bad luck. But then the horse came back and he came back with six wild horses. So suddenly he was lucky again. And his neighbors were jealous of him. But then his son rode one of the wild horses and broke his leg.
所以现在这个老人又倒霉了，因为他的儿子摔断了腿。他的邻居们想，哦，可怜的家伙，他真倒霉。但后来发生了一场战争，一些征兵官来到村里征召年轻人，但他的儿子没有被征召，因为他摔断了腿。所以现在农夫又幸运了。所以无论如何，这是一个可爱的故事，暗示有时发生在我们身上最好的事情实际上与发生在我们身上最坏的事情是同一件事。这让我想起了一次我和一群朋友在除夕夜参加的晚宴。我们互相问了一个问题，那一年发生的最好的事件是什么？
And so now this old man was unlucky again because his son had a broken leg. And his neighbors were thinking, oh, poor guy, he's so unlucky. But then there was a war going on and some conscription officers came to the village to draft young men, but his son wasn't drafted because he had a broken leg. And so now the farmer was lucky again. So anyway, it's a lovely story that suggests that sometimes the best thing that has happened to us is actually the same thing as the worst thing that has happened to us. And it reminds me of actually a dinner that I went to once with a bunch of friends on New Year's Eve. And we asked each other the question, what is the best event that happened that year?
而那一年发生在我们身上最坏的事情是什么。对大多数人来说，最好和最坏的事件是同一件事。就像有人被解雇了，但后来他们得到了一份更好的工作，或者他们结束了一段关系，但现在他们更快乐了，或者他们处于一段更好的关系中。所以是的，这真的总是让我印象深刻，你知道，那显示了最好和最坏的事情可以是同一件事。我喜欢你在书中引用威廉·布莱克的那句话，它优雅地描述了这一点。是的，我喜欢威廉·布莱克。他有这句来自《纯真预言》的伟大台词。喜悦与悲伤交织在一起。
And it was the worst thing that happened to us that year. And for most people, the best and the worst event was the same thing. It was like someone got laid off from a job but then they got an even better job or they broke up a relationship but now they're happier or they're in a better relationship. So yeah it really always struck me kind of you know how that that show that kind of the the best thing and the worst thing can be the same thing. I love the line you have in the book from William Blake that describes this so elegantly. Yes, I love William Blake. He has this great line from AGRES of Innocence. Joy and woe are woven fine.
索尼娅·柳博米尔斯基是加州大学河滨分校的心理学家。她是《幸福的方法》和《幸福的神话》等书的作者。索尼娅，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。和你交谈真是太棒了。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·科雷尔、克里斯汀·王、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯，
Sonia Lubamirsky is a psychologist at the University of California Riverside. She is the author of the books, The How of Happiness and the Myths of Happiness. Sonia, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar Samaisu. It was wonderful to talk to you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Correll, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes,
和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是凯蒂·贝克。凯蒂是Stitcher内容运营的高级经理。距离我们第一次见到凯蒂已经过去大约一年了，在这一年里，她帮助我们处理了各种各样的事情，从大型音频项目到紧急技术问题。她是那种以技巧和
and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Katie Baker. Katie is a senior manager of content operations at Stitcher. It's been about a year since we first met Katie and in that year she has helped us with all sorts of things, from big audio projects, to urgent technical questions. She's one of those people who gets things done with skill and
效率完成工作，并让它看起来很容易的人，尽管幕后发生了很多工作。非常感谢你，凯蒂。欲了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请务必订阅我们的每周通讯。你会发现非常感谢你，凯蒂。那是N-E-W-S点hiddenbrain点org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
efficiency and makes it look easy, even though a lot of work is happening behind the scenes. Thank you so much Katie. For more Hidden Brain, be sure to subscribe to our weekly newsletter. You'll find Thank you so much Katie. That's N-E-W-S dot hiddenbrain dot org. I'm Shankar Vidantum. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
效率很高，看起来毫不费力，尽管幕后做了大量的工作。非常感谢你，凯蒂。想了解更多《Hidden Brain》的内容，请务必订阅我们的每周通讯。你会找到非常感谢你，凯蒂。网址是 N-E-W-S 点 hiddenbrain 点 org。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。下周见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。